didn't Paul McCartney explain a
collusion and the mullah report to John
Lennon well this I do for myself I
really feel like where we are in our
lives sort of wisdom and appreciation I
want John and Paul to talk to each other
yes I don't care how and then it became
a time machine where you know cuz John
left us in 1980 so then and now I lately
I've been doing Paul McCartney
explaining the Lennon so what's going on
down there pole Oh big whoop to do with
the Orangemen the big orange man I host
the orange man you know jumpy the
president I told you about he's a big
orange man he's got little white circles
around his eyes he's got like cotton
candy hair that swirls about you know I
said maybe using Koontz with the
Russians in cahoots yeah you know I'd do
anything that would be do so they hire
this man named EULA you know he's a very
you know he's a different looking
gentleman really narrow in the top of
this head you know and his cheeks go out
like a big chipmunk you know and they
gave him like 25 million quid you know
to investigate you know he went through
a million places of paper and all these
interviews and he said you know I guess
he's not in goods
sounds very strange and then there was
Hillary's emails you know they didn't
know what to do what's an email found
the Cavanaugh hearings when everybody
was so flipped out it just occurred to
me that if Paul McCartney read the news
he'd still get the news but it wouldn't
be depressing it would be like you know
what are they trying to do we're trying
to get a top judge of man John you know
judge a man so the girl just got this
guy Kavanagh seems like a nice nice
enough bloke you know maybe a bit of a
suds Mike you know what do you mean we
like to be here too you know and so they
said all right you could be the top
Georgia man and then a bird from
California says hold on hold on Tino
went doobly doo bee doo doo bee on me
you know just makes it lighter I don't
know
well you can throw me a news story told
what about John doesn't understand the
college cheating scared the little
figure that want to know what's happened
what happened down this you know and
they said oh gonna get me kid in the top
top typically top of school you know and
they gave all this money it was not
enough I said what if we say they rose
what do you mean rowers they like rose
and college
what is row enough to do with college
that lets you in the college these two
girls you know they they they put them
on little little playful rowers you have
in a room little like you exercise Rosie
they took pictures and the father gave a
half million dollars they said could
they go to college but they didn't even
want to go why would they put him in
there if they didn't want to go there on
Instagram what Instagram
that's something Keith Moon used to
snort